chess.com is here with thomas brody
sangster who played u.s champion
benny watts in the queen's gambit now netflix
most watched scripted miniseries of all time
thank you thomas for taking the time to
talk with me and all the chess.com users
thank you um i've read that you learned how to
play drums for love actually and you learned how
to play guitar with your left hand to play paul
mccartney uh this role though you had already
played a previous character that was in the chess
community this was kind of like your second time
playing a chess correct character did that make
it a little bit easier to step into our subculture
um i mean somewhat yeah i mean the the other thing
i did was i mean i was playing um a quite talented
chess player but it was more about um world war
two resistance and um uh it was it was quite a
kind of a side part of it um and it was a kind
of hunt between me and uh and a big nazi badly
that was kind of coming after me so there was a
kind of crossover between that and chessboard and
this was much more chess focused i see what
uh these three disciplines though what is more
difficult to make look convincing on camera
drums guitar with your left hand or chess
um
that's a hard one i mean you you just want to do
the best that you can do to your ability because
also you know you're that's why i love talking
to you because you know that when you when you're
pretending to be someone that is
supposedly very good at something
the main person you're thinking of is people
who are actually very good at it and you know
that they're the they're going to be the ones
that pick you apart the most so whether you're
a drummer or a left-handed guitarist or um you
know big big big chess player um you're going to
be very very critical so that's your main kind of
audience that you're going for drums you literally
have to hit them so if you aren't in time it
doesn't look right so you have to be perfect um
with chess it was more about the finesse and
being able to kind of just look confident moving
chess pieces around the board um in terms
of actually learning um openings or uh
you know really understanding the games in which
you're playing and and the reason for taking each
pieces was kind of not quite as important um and i
suppose fingers on a on a fretboard are important
but less obvious than drumming so i say drumming
i'd say drumming probably we're exactly right it's
very hard to please any subculture when a movie's
made about it but i don't know if you know this
uh this series has been heaped with praise from
inside the chess community for accuracy and the
feel of being at a tournament so you deserve a lot
of credit for that um there's been a lot of movies
that have made about chess during your lifetime
some of them have even been big hollywood releases
but nothing has done what the queen's gamut has
done to grow chess i mean it's hard to even buy a
chess set they're all sold out our website traffic
is getting five times the normal number of users
so my question is why the queen's gambit
why do you think this was different than
all the other chess movies and series to
be honest i don't really know um i don't um
all i do now is that um the people who made this
show um were all phenomenally talented and all
very willing and wanting of creativity
of wanting to tell a story and
wanted to do it right and do it justice and
although it's very very chess focused um that
was a very very important thing to get right
it was also just as important to make sure that
it came across as a real story as it you you are
watching human beings and you are and then there's
then there's also getting it period correct and
that you know so everyone that came together to
make this project did their utmost to make it as
realistic and as well even though it's actually
heightened you know it's a very stylized piece
as well i mean so it's not super realistic but
it's it taps into a sense of reality that i think
is key to making something successful people only
enjoy watching stuff if they can relate to it
or if they can kind of somewhat understand it so
making a movie or or a show requires a huge
collaboration of a lot of people and and and
bringing those people together so that
they all work in unity is very very key
and uh that's what we experienced on set and
the fact that it translated to film is kind of
no surprise the surprise is that it did very very
well and people seemed to love it i knew that it
was going to be a good a good piece but i thought
it would be in a very kind of cliquey um you know
small world of an audience um i didn't
realize it would have the reach that it
does but i think the reason that it does that
is because it's just done it's just done well
makes sense um and in a previous interview
i've heard you praise the hyper realism
that was assisted by some of the chess consultants
i've interviewed bruce pandolfini about it
can you point to one or two things that that he
specifically taught you that helped you ma uh you
know become benny watts as a chess player well we
we played several times just back and forth and um
he he i would just take pieces and they would
go no no no that was that was rubbish that was
rubbish do it again and i'd do it again and you
go that was it that was it i was like i i didn't
really see the difference he was like do it again
and then i did it again he said no no that was
rubbish dude do it again do it again and we'll
just take pieces over and out and you just he
said you know get used to the weight of the pieces
in your hands because you're playing someone that
has moved these pieces around for years and years
and years and studied and studied and studied and
and it kind of probably has a relationship with
each piece you know you know your relationship
with your rooks or you you have a favoritism of
your bishops or you you know which pieces do you
like the most and so he kind of brought although
i wasn't really learning really how to play chess
i was learning the what a chess player may fall
in love with about the game and he was that was
i think that was quite clever because there was
nowhere near enough time to actually really truly
understand the purpose of every move and and
what it all meant and you know that takes years
and years and years of understanding and playing
so what he did was like kind of try to teach us
how to fall in love with the game and how to
look like you know exactly what you're doing
um and so with that there's um another element
of technique but then there's also an element
of flair and they were quite good all of the chess
team were quite good at working with us to try and
create individual flares of how we might
take pieces how how we might hit the clock um
you're like beth knocks over other people's kings
which is just outrageous um but that's her little
thing and um that adds to it um that adds to her
own little techniques so every they were very good
at like trying to figure out everyone's little own
way of playing so i'm curious did you either buy
osmosis or intentionally become a slightly better
player did you play some fun games off the set
anything yeah no no i did and i even learned a
couple of openings which are completely gone now
um but at the moment yeah we were we were
playing with some um some great players and
we were very much invested in that world and
uh i was excited by it i i loved it i saw it as
you know it's a beautiful game that's been
played for hundreds and hundreds of years and
um is kind of infinitely complicated and the
the knowledge that you have to understand the
memory of each game that's being played in the
past and then kind of put that into reflection
of what you need to do in front of your board
and it's just moving bits of wood around the
board that's all it is but it's i i learned
the beauty of it and that's what i would say
that's great to hear um and there's a scene where
you uh what we call a blindfolded game in a car
with beth doesn't literally mean blindfolded
just means without the use of a chess set but
uh this is a skill that comes to all chess players
without ever intentionally trying to do it it's a
bit like taking the tube every day and you just
at some point you just know the system of london
it just happens um so i'm curious were you around
the chest enough throughout the months of filming
where you can kind of close your eyes and see
a chess board and if i say pawn to king four
you can visualize what that looks like did you
have enough chess in you to be able to do that
no okay no in fact those lines are some of the
hardest lines to learn because it was just it to
me it was like code um and if you got one wrong
it that the whole thing didn't make sense so it
had to be spot on perfect um so it was a very hard
thing to learn i just learnt them as lines i was
not visualizing them as a uh on a chess board um
at all no i was completely incapable of doing that
that's all right it takes years
for most of us so um in this series
fashion is kind of like its own
character and you were i don't know
maybe like an indiana jones but i want
to ask about the knife whose idea was it
to add the knife to your wardrobe it was scots
and you know it never comes out stays sheathed
the whole time i don't um it's a weird one it's a
strange one but i think it's just his own like um
just his weird little defensive thing it's a it's
another prop that he uses to kind of unsettle
people and and to make people ask questions um
i mean that that character he doesn't fit the
archetype chess player and i think he does that
intentionally to kind of it's probably a tactic
i think it's a tactic to unsettle his opponent the
fact he's just bizarre looking strange looking and
he carries a knife i mean why would you need a
knife um and the fact he never uses it he never
peels an orange and never does anything with it
it's uh it might not even be real i don't really
know i'm gonna ask you a bit of an outlandish
theory that i had when i my first viewing of the
series um right before you played the big game
against beth in ohio at the u.s championship
you got your two characters play a series of blitz
chess or speed chess matches and you win all of
them almost like you're hustling her you're taking
her five dollars every time i'm just wondering
though in like washington square in new york city
uh sometimes hustlers they do the typical hustle
they lose a bunch of games until they raise the
stakes i'm just wondering i don't know if beth's
character was sophisticated enough but could she
have lost those games to you on purpose to be
able to beat you the next day in the event where
it really mattered well i don't know uh i don't
think so i don't think so um it's a good point
uh i don't think she'd ever heard of speed chess
or blitz chess uh and i think i basically hustled
her knowing that she i think it was also mainly
to kind of slightly unsettle over the next day
when we're actually playing the real game um
so by that point i had already beaten her 10
times or something so um i think it was more
to kind of see how she played and to slightly
unsettle her um i don't think she lost on purpose
i've been there before i don't think she likes
losing um i mean i mean actually most chess
players i've met during this whole thing uh
despise losing uh it really gets to them which
i found quite anyone that competes in anything
i think just hates losing it's very visceral um
one more idea this was not my idea uh and
this has nothing to do with your character but
is there any chance that cleo is a kgb agent
because that's actually if you read anything about
cold war era chess kgb agents were absolutely at
tournaments so i'm just curious if that could be
i don't know as well that's another good
good spot i have no idea that's a good oh
oh i like that i'm going to say yes because i
like that as it's as a store as a sub storyline
i'm going to ask you a question about your
subculture that i know very little about but um
in the chess world when two chess players meet for
the first time we always know each other's rating
or maybe even their title in chess and so it's
a very hierarchical game you can almost never be
equals as somebody because i know you're raiding
in you know mine is it like that in the acting
world i'm guessing you don't bump into people and
you know exactly how many baftas they've won or
something but um is there any sort of hierarchy
like that in your world no well there probably
is um it's i mean there's ego there's lots of
ego um i don't really care about that too much
i i i also don't get that star struck over people
i i only judge people on whether they're a nice
person and then and then whether they're
talented and whether i can you know work
with them and bounce off of them and have fun
and play in a scene um to me there is no um
there isn't really a hierarchy i mean you
get you know when you when you join a job
you know there's the star and then on the call
sheet you've got number one two three four
five so you're number eight and they're number
one but i mean that's it and it's it's it's
a bit of a joke really um it depends on how
much of a an arse they are but uh most people
actually aren't they're most people are very nice
people um actors are perhaps a little insecure
but uh i tend to not be [ __ ] they tend to be
quite nice people i think and they just want to
um play an experience and get that they're quite
excited to get to work with someone new i mean
that's how i feel and that's my most
most of my experience with others is that
um if you've watched other actors or if you
know other actors um you're more excited to
work with them because you get to see how you
react with them in a scene uh it's more of an
exciting thing than a a one-upmanship there is
no way of kind of winning at acting that's good
to hear in another interview you said that
as a boy you played drafts or we call it
checkers that game is very complex is it complex
enough where a series like this could be made
out of drafts or is chess just got that next level
of complexity that makes this series what it was
i think it's also got more character to it though
as well i mean that there are literally different
characters on a chessboard um i just think it's
a little bit more of an interesting game uh it's
visually just the pieces are more interesting as
well um it's a bit more famous uh i don't know i
mean quite possibly you can make a movie about
anything um as long as it's well written and
well acted well shot uh it doesn't really matter
too much what it's about so yeah i would say so
fantastic i'm just going to ask you one more
question it's something i've wanted to know
hopefully the chess.com users do too if we had
a chess tournament with all of the actors not
counting any of the professional chess consultants
like bruce who would win that chess tournament
now i never played him but apparently jacob
um i can't remember his second name now
um jacob who plays um photographer guy uh i can't
remember his character name either bloody yell
um apparently he's quite good um
yeah i never played him but apparently he's
actually bloody good so i would say him fantastic
maybe we'll have to organize that someday well
thank you so much um it's hard for me to express
how much you've done for the chess community it's
been awesome to see um i wish you all on your
career yeah thank you thomas brodie thanks for
spending some time with us thank you very much